[Music]
so today we're going to cancel
with a vengeance grace church school
grace church school
achieves the double woke whammy of being
both in manhattan and episcopal which is
just a long way of saying
that the school is a nest of moral
confusion and insanity
case in point they recently released
their inclusive language guide
and within this 12-page screed the
reader will discover that words like mom
dad and parents are non-inclusive and
therefore offensive and therefore should
not be used
now we'll dive deeper into the guide in
a moment but first here's a local news
report about the controversy surrounding
the guide
including the reaction from the
expectedly pathetic specimen who runs
the school
we'll hear what he has to say as well
let's listen
grace church school an independent
school in greenwich village prides
itself in welcoming students of all
faiths or no faith at all
but now it's finding itself facing
criticism for encouraging
words that promote an inclusive
environment like saying people instead
of boys and girls
and grown up instead of parent since not
all children are being raised by a
mother
and or father one person tweeted grace
church school in new york should be
ashamed of themselves saying
that you can't use the words mom and dad
and you're supposed to use
folks or family george davidson is head
of grace church school
we're not telling people not to call
their parents mom and dad that's the
silliest thing anybody ever came up
and it's not even a word police it is
rather a guide to inclusive language if
you want to use it
back in september the school posted this
inclusive language guide at the request
of teachers and parents
who wanted help in making sure their
interactions were affirming and uniting
parents we spoke with say they're
supportive of the guidelines and proud
the school is also describing best
practices for discussing faith
learning differences and physical
disabilities like choosing the words
physically disabled instead of
handicapped we can't lump people
together
and assume anything about people and
that's at the core of what this
is about natalie egan is the founder of
translator which builds diversity equity
and inclusion analytic software for
schools
she applauds grace church's pioneering
spirit as we look to the future
you know it's really important that we
start to you know shape our
our future leaders to to be inclusive of
all people
you know regardless of of anything
whoever they are
it is what we're proud of whoever they
are
it's what we're proud of well i might
critique that statement if i had the
slightest idea what it meant
whoever they are it's what we're proud
of but this is what wokeness actually is
most of the time total nonsense
literally i mean nonsense in the
definitions
definitional sense of the word as in
things that make no sense
wokeness is in practice a jumble of
semi-coherent buzzwords mixed together
in entirely incoherent ways
that's because the core idea the only
idea
really is that feelings come before all
else the only thing that matters
the only thing period is how the
individual feels
well certain individuals anyway a very
select group of individuals as it turns
out wokeness
is not only incoherent but elitist and
oppressive it puts
the feelings and psychological comfort
of a tiny minority of the population
above the emotional and practical
concerns
of everyone else on earth how many
people on the globe as a percentage
would actually find references to mom
and dad or even parents
as offensive how many would profess
themselves otherwise
by such words what percent of people
would have a problem with it
0.1 percent 0.01 0.001
whatever the percentage is and whoever
those people are and however numerous
they are or aren't
they are all that matter that's the
message it's only them they're the only
ones that matter
so let's take a look at this guide it
says right at the top the goal of this
guide is to provide the
the community with more inclusive
language that is aligned with the
mission of grace church school
while we recognize hateful language that
promotes racism misogyny homophobia and
other forms of discrimination
are already addressed in our school
handbooks we also recognize that we can
do more than ban hateful language we can
use language to create welcoming and
inclusive spaces
this guide addresses ways we can remove
harmful assumptions
from the way we interact with each other
then there's a chart
and on one side it says instead of and
lists all the phrases that you shouldn't
use
and on the other it says at grace we say
and it lists the alternatives
remember how george davidson the head of
the school assured us that they aren't
banning words like mom and dad don't be
silly
why that's the most ridiculous thing
he's ever heard they're only suggesting
different words that you can use if you
want to
except that in the guide words like mom
and dad are framed as quote
hateful language that promotes racism
misogyny homophobia and other forms of
discrimination
and the alternatives are not offered as
suggestions but as things
we say at grace church school not things
we'd like you to say but things you will
say
so as always with the woke brigade they
enact their insane agenda and then deny
it
and get away with denying it because the
agenda is so insane that normal people
can't believe anyone would actually want
to do this
now looking at the chart here's uh some
of the of the banned words and their
replacements we'll go through some of
these
so it says instead of boys and girls
guys ladies and gentlemen
at grace we say people folks friends
readers
mathematicians last one's kind of
specific
uh instead of when reading a book rather
than boy girl on this page
say child person character
instead of using pet names like
sweetheart honey or similar
say the child's name or child slash
friend in the blue shirt
yes that's that's a that's a great way
to build rather than than saying
sweetheart or honey just say hey kid in
the blue shirt get over here
um and then uh let's see so that's
a lot of gender stuff and then with
families it says instead of saying mom
and dad
say grown-ups folks or family
instead of parents say grown-ups folks
family or guardians
um instead of nanny or babysitter say
say caregiver or guardian
why is that better than nanny who knows
but just just because nanny is a word
that people have used in the past and
that makes it offensive
let's come up with a different word that
means exactly the same thing and there's
no reason why
one is better than the other um
instead of husband wife boyfriend or
girlfriend say spouse
partner significant other
and then and then it gives you so those
are those are the language guides
and that goes into ra race and ethnicity
instead of saying diverse or minority
say person of color
instead of asking where are you from ask
what is your cultural
ethnic background and instead of saying
what race are you
ask how they self-identify well that's
important because
you know it's they might identify as a
race that they aren't
so you got to make sure that we account
for that now a lot can be said about
these kinds of orwellian speech rules
but
one thing that really jumps out is just
how boring and sterile and flavorless
they seek to make human communication
remove all the personality from it all
the character
right instead this is why we take
sweetheart take away sweetheart and
honey and you know the kind of pet names
especially that women
will use for for kids kid in the blue
shirt
child in the blue shirt organism in the
blue shirt
please come here presently take all the
specific
specificity out as well you know your
mom and dad are folks
your wife is partner this is not only an
oddly distanced and neutral way to refer
to your own loved ones
but it also really doesn't tell the
listener anything about them
i mean a partner can be anyone you could
have a partner during a science lab in
10th grade
folks is a word that can be applied to
your parents or to a random group of
strangers
yes the real words the better words wife
and mom and dad are
exclusive but that's the point in order
for me to know what you're saying
you have to speak in such a way as to
exclude all of the things
you're not saying i have to know what
you're not saying in order to know what
you are
saying so the leftist rules are not only
not only lead to bland language but the
language that hardly succeeds in being
language
at all because it hardly conveys meaning
and that's what language is supposed to
do
now one other point to make here i said
that these kinds of speech codes are
meant to cater to a small minority and
they are
but the idea is to make it so that
eventually
the small minority is not a minority
the language changes don't reflect
changes and cultural sensibilities or
tastes
they're meant to affect those changes
cause them
they don't reflect the changes they're
supposed to effect the changes
the school isn't so much saying that mom
and dad are
seen as offensive words to lots of
people but that mom and dad
should be seen as offensive to lots of
people
see the rules from the left are
prescriptive not descriptive
it is prescription disguised as
description
the people changing the language want to
change the way
you see the world they want to change
your values your beliefs
and changing language can be an
effective way of achieving that
so we make the mistake we make a mistake
when we boil all this stuff down to the
left just being overly sensitive
snowflakes
and all of that sensitivity really has
nothing to do with it
the truth is a lot more sinister than
that this is brainwashing
this is just another form of
indoctrination
and for that grace church school is
certainly without a doubt absolutely
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt well show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content